I ran reportedly is still allowing
inspections and complying with the
nuclear agreement it's signed in 2015
even after President Trump withdrew the
u.s. from the deal
ambassador Wendy Sherman spent four
years negotiating with Iran and world
leaders on the nuclear accord even
powering through several minor injuries
during the process she also worked for
the Clinton State Department where she
was a policy coordinator on North Korea
the distinguished diplomat began her
career as a social worker her new book
is not for the faint of heart
lessons encourage power and persistence
she explains how people can apply what
she learned in high-stakes negotiations
to get what they want in everyday life
we love this Sherman has just been
appointed the new director of the
Harvard Kennedy School Center for public
leadership good morning good morning
norm and congratulations on that
appointment very exciting very much
there's a lot to talk to you and I want
to get to the Iran and nuclear and North
Korea stuff in just a minute but first
for someone who's negotiated deals with
Iran what can we learn from your career
about just everyday type of negotiations
we may have I think that what I want
people to understand is that to do a
good negotiation to really be a good
diplomat you need courage you need to be
able to persist you need to understand
you've got to have a team around you
just like we have to have families
around us to be able to get through our
day and to get through our careers we
have to be able to really understand the
power in our relationships you know I've
been very fortunate I've got now a 38
year marriage and it's because we
understand what we come with to that
marriage and we help each other out so
what I've tried to do in this book is
take this high-stakes negotiation you
say about Iran and North Korea Middle
East peace Cuba and say here's a skill
set that we all can use in our everyday
life to try to make things better and to
own our own power well you write about
negotiating during the Iran deal you
write about crying at one point even
because one offhand comment that you
made led to death to Wendy Sherman
chance in the streets of Iran I think
about being authentic because I thought
about how you write about that book but
do you also have to watch what you say
because it can be incredibly dangerous
in indeed it is incredibly dangerous I
regretted having made that statement
what was the same the statement was the
deception is in their DNA it was an
answer to a question from a senator and
a Senate Foreign Relations Committee
hearing and that led to death to Wendy
Sherman on the streets of Tehran I also
during this negotiation had emails pop
up to both me and my daughter that my
husband was having an affair in Europe
while I was negotiating I never quite
found out who did that though these days
we might have some clue about who's
sending those kind of emails yeah so
there were lots of obstacles along the
way but I think one of the things I've
learned through life is I'm going to
come out the other side and if I can
gather people around me to support me
every place I've worked I've created a
support group largely of women I think
you both probably understand this John
you probably understand it in your own
way as well but I think women in the
workplace need a support group to know
that they're not crazy that they can
juggle if you're a mom which I was
juggle what they have in their lives and
come through the other side and I think
that is a sense of confidence that we
all need to make it through ly now let
me ask you about that ability diplomats
need to have to read the person across
from the table often from another
culture give us what it's like to
negotiate with the North Koreans who you
spend a lot of time with and who are
obviously very much in the news today I
you really do have to understand and and
quite frankly Jon the difference between
autocrats and Democrats is autocrats
really are impulsive they are short-term
errs they think about what they want
Democrats think long term understand
history understand that we have an
obligation to the future and to
understand those cultures so that when
you're sitting across from North Koreans
who live in this tiny little world more
a cult than a country that they really
are cut off from the world Kim jong-un
has nothing to do except care about the
survival of himself and his regime
whereas the president in United States
most president United States anyway but
that they have a responsibility for many
many things and the safety and
prosperity of the world you've been to
North Korea yes right and when we were
reporting there our government minders
said you know we all want
denuclearization in North Korea but we
want everyone to play by the same rules
is there a difference
quickly wonder if you could between how
North Koreans view denuclearization and
Americans absolutely
for us we mean getting rid of their
nuclear weapons and their long-range
ballistic missiles that could deliver
them for North Korea denuclearization
means that we should leave the Korean
Peninsula with all of our troops that we
should make sure their regime survives I
think that the president secretary
Pompeyo
now the new envoy Steve Egan have a very
very very tough road ahead and I don't
think they have a plan for getting to
the end of that story
ambassador Wendy Sherman thanks so much
the book is not for the faint of heart